is somebody who's uh mmqb is must read
every single week this week in
particular because it takes you behind
the scenes of how
the niners and the dolphins got together
and then the eagles got involved albert
breer
senior writer of the mmqb back here on
the rich eisen show how are you albert
i'm pretty good how are you doing rick i
am doing well so uh
this sounds like based on your reporting
like a good old-fashioned nba trade
although it wasn't just all announced
at once like a three-team or a
hardened palooza got announced earlier
in this
regular season for the nba but it just
does does sound like the dolphins
needed to get that piece with the eagles
done before saying yes to the 49ers
correct
yeah and that's what made it so
sensitive um you know and i think it
really took a lot of trust on the part
of the three teams you know john lynch
pulling the strings in san francisco
chris greer pulling the strings in miami
and of course howie rosen in
philadelphia
um you know because i think you know for
for san francisco to offer what they did
they wanted confidentiality because they
didn't want you know
to touch off you know a flurry of offers
you know coming to the coming of the
dolphins and the dolphins respected that
and you know in exchange the the niners
gave the dolphins time to go and
um seek out a partner to get the other
part of the deal done and so
um it's complicated in the nfl there's a
lot of moving pieces there
um you know the dolphins didn't want to
go that far
back um i've got my suspicions on some
reasons for that
um you know but you know i i think in
the end really
it was about keeping the train on the
tracks you know over the last three
weeks and
um you know i think it's a it's a good
commentary on everybody involved that
they were able to kind of keep this
under their hats
um you know the eagles felt like jamar
chase probably goes fifth overall to the
bengals
and you know after that they felt like
you know what they'd be getting at six
wasn't that different than what they'd
be getting at 12
and uh this would allow them to get an
extra first round pick for next year
when they're really going to be able to
turn the page and get younger
obviously san francisco goes in and now
takes control of his destiny
at quarterback you know the dolphins
come out of all of this with more assets
and still only having to move back three
spots so
um how safe is the assumption
that the niners contacted the jets first
and we're told
no thanks to the same deal or something
maybe even more improved
than the what the dolphin said yes to
i'm told they didn't have any talks on
the second overall take which is a
fascinating piece to all this
um and and i i i can tell you that the
niners did have internal discussions on
sam darnold
um and there were um discussions between
the jets and the niners on sam darnold
but
um you know really there never was
a discussion between the jets and the
niners about the second overall pick and
my feeling on that is that the niners
you know went through vetting um the
whole
situation with sam darnold and came away
with the idea that the jets were going
to stick there
too and take a quarterback so yeah i
think they knew
you know just because of the sensitivity
of everything that if they were going to
move forward with a big offer to move
into the top five
um you know they didn't they wanted to
kind of keep that their intentions there
quiet
and so you know going around and
checking with different teams
um on you know what they'd be willing to
do with their top five picks
um you know that certainly could be a
way of getting out what they were doing
and and again it could
kind of change the conditions in the
market um
you know and so you know again like i
think so much of this for for john lynch
for kyle shanahan
was to be able to move forward quietly
on a deal
that was going to be very complicated
for everybody to get done
no i i hear you albert breer but i mean
it just strikes me that if you're going
to go to
three two is even the better spot
because what one is
you know an absolute pounding of sand
there's no question about that
so you know that makes no sense that
they wouldn't
at least surmise um
you know what the jets would want for
two
so are you saying that based on what
people are telling you there's a
possibility joe douglas is watching the
pro day with zach wilson
hearing the news and then goes across
the field
to the 49ers at some point what gives i
mean you didn't even call us yeah i mean
i i i i
i like look like it doesn't make a ton
of sense to me either i'm just
telling you what my reporting is is
there and i'm with you i'm with you 100
logically you would think like if you're
the niners i mean all right like we know
who the first takes gonna be right so
maybe it's not even worth the phone call
to jacksonville
but yeah i mean i'm with you that like
logically you can look at it and you can
say
well it started two and worked out you
know what i mean like but
um yeah i think the niners because
they'd had those discussions on darnold
they felt like they had a better feel
for it you know what i mean and so
right uh i mean look like there's
photographic evidence
um i know it was out there i'm sure you
saw too there was a picture of
john lynch standing there with joe
douglas and robert sala
and uh at zac wilson's pro day so you
would have to think
that that potentially came up you know
like well why didn't you make us an
offer for two
you know and so i don't know what was
said in that discussion but
you know if i was joe douglas i would
certainly want to know if they hadn't
reached out
uh about the second pick why they didn't
reach out about the second pick
albert breer the mmqb senior nfl
reporter here on the rich eisen show you
have to check out what he's written
about
this uh that remarkable friday in the
nfl draft
during zach wilson's pro day uh right
here on the rich eisen show so the jimmy
g
of it all um clearly if you're going at
number three
as you pointed out in your piece and
daniel jeremiah pointed out in the
second hour mac jones is more nfl ready
just because of the program from which
he comes and how long he was in right
and how
much reps he's got compared to justin
fields with all due respect to your alma
mater as well as
um you know trey lance um that said
you know you is is jimmy g gonna be the
guy do you think or do you think this is
one of those things where well we want
the best possible offer for him after we
get
our quarterback third overall and we
want to make it seem like
it's difficult to get them as opposed to
everyone
out there i think two things could
change
the jimmy g situation okay um
you know either one they wind up with a
opportunity with another veteran
quarterback somewhere
um that comes along over the next few
weeks and maybe that veteran
quarterback's a little cheaper and
allows them to move jimmy g
maybe that happens that's a possibility
the other thing that could happen is
somebody just blows them away
and offers them a one or something crazy
for jimmy right
so that's number two um but absent that
rich i mean
i i think the best way and i know i'm
not the first one
yeah i'm probably not the first person
you've heard this from the the right
comparison is the chiefs in 2017.
um you know like the niners now they've
got
the the chiefs had a a coach and a
general manager going into year five of
their program
um like the like the niners now the
chiefs were looking at a group of
quarterbacks in the draft that were
pretty raw
um and you know like the the niners now
the chiefs had a
roster that they felt like was ready to
contend and
the veteran quarterback they had on
their roster had two years left on his
contract
so that allowed the chiefs to play a
year with alex smith
sit patrick mahomes and then still turn
around a year later after alex played
really well
and trade him after the year you know
and so
i think the way the niners are looking
at this right now is we've got a
championship
roster today and we can come go in and
compete for a super bowl today
and do we really want to put that in the
hands of a rookie
or who are we better off sitting the
rookie
letting him learn behind jimmy and
giving jimmy a chance to reestablish who
he is the starter in the nfl
we wound up we wind up contending in
2021 and then everybody wins because
jimmy's got more value after the year
and we've gotten you know our young
quarterbacks from time to develop
especially
when you consider those three young
quarterbacks you talked about this is a
pretty crazy number
uh a set of numbers here rich mac jones
has 17 college starts trey lance has 17
college starts
justin fields has 22 college stars
and so i mean if you look at it i mean
remember when kyle traded for jimmy who
had been in the league for three and a
half years
he still waited a month to play him you
remember that like didn't trust him for
a full month before he put him on the
field this is a guy who was in his
fourth year in the league
and so i think when you kind of look at
like kind where they are from a roster
standpoint
how ready they believe they are to get
back to contending for a super bowl they
can just get a little healthier
it makes sense why you could look at
this and say
well it's not worth it for them to move
jimmy's garoppolo for a
three um if they're going to expose
themselves in that way where
you know maybe in a month they get the
rookie in the building and he's just not
ready to play yet
albert prayer here on the rich eisen
show where does desean watson figure
into all of this
um we all are reading about the
assorted accusations that are being
hurled in his direction and the sheer
volume of it makes all of us sit here
and think well some of it's got to be
true
right even though none of it might be
true or all of it may be true
he's being caught um in this tidal wave
right now
but to me i mean he this removes san
francisco off that board
uh if the jets said no to this or at
least said you know we're
we're we're trading sam donald maybe
they're
off this board did did the niners ever
reach out
because they you know the the three ones
and the three is exactly
the construct one would say of a deal
that
that might needed to be added to prior
to everything going on with watson's
uh off the field stuff to use the phrase
yeah um
what do you think here well everybody's
got the same answer from houston
um which you know at least leading up to
the legal situation
the answer team is calling the texans
got from nick casario
the general manager there was you can
ask me about anybody but the quarterback
you know we're open to talking about
anybody in the roster but the
quarterback so
um they've been definitive with other
teams for most of the last few weeks
last couple of months that they you know
aren't going to move to sean watson i
also think it's really hard to have a
take on this
you know rich because uh at the legal
situation at least because
you're either a indicting desean watson
which isn't fair
or you're be not taking the you know
accusation seriously enough if you have
a strong take on it so
i think that's sort of put a lot of the
teams in the position where they're
sitting back and saying
well we can't justify sending
an enormous amount of draft capital to
houston to go and get this guy until we
have clarity in the situation
right houston you can't walk away from a
25 year old franchise quarterback unless
you're getting that return
the one thing that's sort of interesting
here though and i just kind of keep an
eye on this
i think the dolphins you look at where
they are right now
and their insistence on getting back up
into the top ten
right and their assistance on winding up
with the sixth pick
and now they're sitting there with six
and 18 and they've got a young
quarterback they could deal
i just i just think it's interesting
that like the dolphins
who have been so good with their asset
management over the last few years and
chris greer has done a fantastic job
building up that war chest
you know they have been you know in a
lot of cases if you look at it a move
back team right like in a
let's trade for future assets let's find
value and in this case
they were like we'll go back but we
don't want to go back that far
so you sort of wonder now if desean were
to come available would that
sixth pick now be a better chip to deal
than the 12th pick and if you combine it
with another first round pick this year
it's just sort of interesting that way
so i think miami you know could be in it
i i
the jets would kick tires on it although
they seem like they're pretty happy with
what they saw in zack wilson
so not sure how they compare one against
the other right now
um yeah i mean it's it's interesting and
san francisco of course because now they
don't have the future assets
would be one of those teams where you'd
look at them and say okay they're
probably not going to be in the running
for deshawn
albert here on the rich eyes and i also
by the way by the way i would not i
the two the two teams that i would not
discount on that
like that have obviously been involved
from the start i think are caroline and
denver i think those two teams are
you know they're just very involved in
everything quarterback-wise this
offseason yeah i mean because
you know last one for you here albert is
you know um
the the the criticism if you will
that i'm i'm seeing about the niners
giving this all up for a player who's
yet to play in the nfl
is like this is the the deal that you
could get a real deal
either 25 year old desean watson or 32
year old russell wilson for even though
i imagine san francisco be the last
place on earth
seattle would ever deem to send russell
wilson
and we've already talked about what
might be an issue with desean watson
and you're always taking a look around
the league at quarterback situations
that could bubble up
a year from now and we're already
talking about maybe in a draft or
either one of these guys for next year
my last thing for you is about aaron
rodgers
because when quarterbacks redo their
contracts that's not news to me
everybody makes it seem like well
that quarterback redid the contract that
means that they're capped strong and
that the
general manager has been burning the
midnight oil and calling everybody
desperately to get calf space this is
stuff that you know when they sign a
contract is essentially assumed
this is going to happen if not ever
already verbally agreed to will redo the
contract at that point
for the cap issue the
the story usually is when a quarterback
says no i will not
and it appears that's the case with
aaron rodgers in green bay right like so
what is the there that is there
albert on that well you know
i think though i i've felt this way
since the idea of him restructuring came
up
that this could be an elegant solution
right like that there is some tension
that that aaron rodgers put some
pressure on them
um and that you know obviously they've
got a young quarterback in their roster
now that they like
like how do you solve that and and how
do you please aaron rodgers without
going completely overboard and you know
abandoning the principles with which
that i mean that franchise has been
built it's the same tree
of personnel people that have built that
franchise since the early 90s you know
starting with ron wolf and so you know
there's a certain set of principles with
which they operate
and um you know so how do you not break
your principles
but also you know work with your
quarterback and trying to give him the
best
situation um going forward in the
twilight of his career
and and i've felt like you know since
the idea came up of restructuring
to me like an elegant solution would be
going to aaron
and presenting him with a plan and
saying
here's what we're going to do with the
money we're going to clear up and if we
can clear out x amount of cab space we
normally don't mortgage contracts this
way
but we understand this is a special
situation
so if we clear say 20 million dollars in
cap space by restructuring your contract
a little bit
maybe we get a little money in your
pocket earlier and then we're gonna do x
y and z and we've talked to this team or
this team
about potential trades you know we're
gonna get you some more help
and i i really think that that could
wind up being
just a good conclusion for everybody
because i think a big part of what
happened with aaron and why he spoke out
the way he spoke out was he looked
around
in that conference championship round
and he saw how
you know urgently the the bills have
built around uh
josh allen bringing in stefan diggs how
urgently the chiefs have acted around
patrick mahomes while they had him on
the rookie contract and then of course
you know how the buccaneers have built
with
just i mean i'd say built was abandoned
right
over the last year around tom brady and
so i think that's really what rogers
wants
um and to me like you know the way to
find the
the end game here could be all right
we're gonna work with you on a
restructure
and with the money we save we're going
to do x y and z
so you know that we're acting with some
urgency because you don't know how many
years you got left
albert thanks for the time uh your piece
is phenomenal again today that
everyone should check out on the mmqb
and this um this
interview went as i had hoped and
expected unlike a certain first round
um tournament contest um
might you know for for some not not all
but just for some
so engulfed in spring football coverage
right now i know you are oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah hey but i'll be the
bigger man here good luck tomorrow night
don't make me show our text
albert those are private they are indeed
thankfully called bud you take care of
it
all right thanks robert everybody hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here